Are there examples of a better approach?
Yes. Earlier I mentioned health maintenance organizations.
And we'll now look at the oldest.
Kaiser Permanente was founded in 1945 by
industrialists Henry J. Kaiser and physician Sidney R. Garfield.
Edgar Kaiser famously described its economic model as "The less Kaiser does for patients,
the more money it makes."
This is because Kaiser offers a prepaid plan to employers.
Kaiser agrees to provide all needed care for a fixed amount per year.
The history actually dates to 1933,
when Garfield opened the Contractors General Hospital with 12 beds to
treat construction workers building the Los Angeles aqueduct in the Mojave Desert.
The hospital was in a precarious financial state.
Fueled by Garfield's desire to treat all patients regardless of their ability to pay.
Harold Hatch, an insurance agent,
proposed that the insurance companies pay the hospital
a total amount in advance for each worker covered.
The financial relationship between the insurance companies and the hospital was
efficient and allowed Garfield to focus on a new idea, preventative health care.
This is the first key takeaway.
When the health care economic model provides the right incentives,
the focus shifts to preventive care in order to avoid costs.
Kaiser is also a leader in care coordination and population health,
two key strategies for managing chronic disease that we'll discuss later on.
To support these strategies,
Kaiser has also been a leader in the use of information technology.
HIMSS is a large,
not-for-profit organization, focused on better health through information technology.
Its annual meeting is by far,
the largest event in the field.
In 2009, Kaiser received the first ever Stage 7 award.
This is HIMSS' highest level of recognition for
an environment where paper charts are no longer used.
That's the second key takeaway.
A care models that work best for
chronic disease rest on the use of information technology.
Kaiser's done well.
And today, it employs 186,000 staff and over
18,000 physicians to serve over 10 million patients in these areas.